um so as you know like it used to be
very traditional right like it used to
be very much like the women stayed home
the men were more providers
um but as like more women enter the
workforce like things change the
development of birth control also
changed a lot of things so
um I'd like to go around and everyone
say what
do you believe do you believe there
should be gender roles in 2022
in relationships could someone else go
first
I don't mind going first I think
that it I think a lot of it depends on
um
who the main Breadwinner is in a
relationship and how much
that person earns as well if you're both
struggling if you're both for a sort of
average average earnings you've got to
split things up make things work with
the interview but if one of you is like
I don't know a millionaire no one's not
yeah you know no matter what that one
earns when it's not a millionaire earns
it doesn't really matter it's individual
so then and then I always also believe
that whoever is the main Breadwinner has
to sort of um
they sort of domination they they lead
the relationship so the other one the
whatever is with the man or woman has to
sort of what kind of fall in line too so
you think whoever makes more should like
submit to the other basically like this
oh yeah yeah sorry sorry yes yes
and that's where things can be
complicated because okay we've believed
that normally it's men that earn more
okay when a woman earns more and
normally it's especially if you earn
significantly more than a partner then
you're gonna probably find some issues
in a relationship long term okay
um I'd say uh I'd say I agree with that
as well but um
in a scenario because obviously back
then it was very much like the woman is
the you know stay at home wife and then
obviously there was a lot of development
with like the females rights and all
that stuff and now it's like
men but generally earned more but now
because obviously like it's a gender
equality and stuff
um women can earn just as much if not
more so it does kind of like
put like um a stop to the kind of like
men earning more inside that stuff type
of thing
um and yeah that's a that's a moment
from okay I feel like
you should do like whatever you're good
at so if someone's good at cooking they
should just do that instead of trying to
push the gender roles let's say the
woman should cook even though the man is
like a chef I just found that kind of
stuff
yeah
do what you're good at in the
relationship and make make balance try
and make balance
I like that part yeah I like I think I
agree with the you know usually I I mean
I guess it's not it's just how it goes
usually whoever earns more the other
person usually submits because I would
say like you just feel like that person
is just not like
over you are like bigger than you but
it's just you that's just how it is but
I also do like that you know whatever
you're good at in the relationship like
you know just do it like you know maybe
the woman doesn't know how to do laundry
and the man's like you know that's his
thing maybe he loves like folding
clothes
being from the I'm I'm sorry being from
the male agenda I don't know any man
that would love folding clothes I
promise you that now any man that does
I'm sorry
um okay so what do you think if they
make the same amount of money
I'd say there's like a 50 50 thing okay
um let's say like you know if there is
like a kid that's on the way maybe and
then I'm assuming like they would like
discuss who would be the one who's like
not like the main caretaker but the one
that like stays home take care of the
kid and then and the other one's like
working to earn money but I don't think
that there is any like man or woman that
should just be like submitting to doing
that I think there has to be a
discussion between the two okay I think
it depends your tax bracket okay tax
bracket yeah I think how much you're
earning yeah
well I would join us if you both are not
earning 50 000 for you for example
that's not a great wage especially in
London it's just a struggling wage in
London and you've got to do things
together I work out together were you
both gonna have to work full time right
so that makes things a bit difficult to
say well you should all you you should
do this you should do this because
you're both doing full-time work
if you're in I know 250 Grand each then
Things become a bit easier because then
you can hype to do things for you yeah
you'd have to worry about who's cooking
because you can go out to eat more often
or you can get someone to cook for you
you have to worry about who's cleaning
up because you can get a cleaning a
cleaner so the generals stop at a
certain salary I think
I think the general is I don't in
today's Saturday no it's difficult it's
very difficult to have specific roles
um what I would say is if one is like I
said if you're both working
then I don't have especially if you're
both working full-time I'm going to roll
things a bit more tricky to work out
um and you guys both mentioned do we
bester yeah and we have a partner now
we're both working and I'm a bit of
cooked cook yeah she just Cooks so well
sometimes it's normal but
um if one of you likes to do if one is a
one of these working that one isn't yeah
it doesn't completely different story
yeah
what if one's like just like naturally
wealthy like they've inherited their
wealth and doesn't need to work and one
has to work like should that person
still work full time it's like one
partner is like just wealthy like from a
wealthy family doesn't actually need to
go to work because I have that wealth
already and then someone would should
you make your partner go to work but I
think I mean if they already have a
wealth and then like they're just like
you know staying in the house they might
as well do like the stuff like you know
otherwise what are you doing just
sitting on your ass yeah while the other
person is like working their ass off and
like you know by the time they get home
then they're tired as hell yeah but oh I
was going to say I was going to build on
the first point that you made in in the
case of like
when a man and a woman have like a baby
and let's see they are like average you
know they make average wage more or less
the same it should be 50 50. but then
the woman at the end of the day still
kind of gets an advantage so it's not
exactly legal because at the end of the
day you can talk about it but the man's
still going to go to work while the
woman stays at home for those nine
months so however many moms that day she
can stay things like what is in the UK
it's like um a year a year about about a
year right and she stays at home and you
know
it could be split between wherever you
could choose who takes a year off
whether it's a man or a woman oh really
but now but naturally it's always the
woman yeah because more often than not
the man earns more than almost it makes
more sense for her and also I mean women
hair you're going to want to Abundant if
your children what have you yeah recover
yeah
what would you say for like after like
you know the kids like a toddler and
like you know we can sometimes again
especially in London sometimes it
sometimes it doesn't even make sense for
her to go back to work because she's
literally just pains going to work fun
Child Care yeah
it's so expensive
having someone else look after them we
got to work because it doesn't make any
sense no but you know as as fathers
right um
[Music]
no no no no I hope I'm no no no no no
wrong way
sorry no no but like we're winning in a
department of like when the day comes
when the kid says first words yeah and
all and the mother was there nurturing
and she says that oh man you must be
human
so